[Music]
morning
chores you're really good picking up
poop ly I am
yep cleaning up the goat area
okay we have a challenge we are going to
milk the goats and we're going to see
who's faster me or Ethan challenge
challenge you to a goat milking
duel well it's harder whoever starts
first is no no we're going to start at
the same time we're each going to take a
te how do you feel about this challenge
Luna
how do you feel about it who do you
think's going to
win I think she pointed to
me nope she knows me she loves me can
you use your other hand on one te no
right just dominant hand one te the end
to okay ready okay are you
ready wait we have wash her off did you
wash her off I washed her off okay Ready
Set Go
oh
man mom's buing pretty fast
e let's go I can't get it it's too
hard here we
going you can do longer bigger squirts
or shorter smaller
squirts look about
even oh my hands Tamp
don't go so fast go with the
flow oh I went too fast I sprinted too
[Music]
soon
okay I think we'll end in about a minute
or
two oh he
SC we'll see let's go you're still in
this I can go for you oh
bird my forearm is going me
[Music]
oh no foam does not count as well foam
does not count as milk ready over oh man
well I don't know cuz there's oh no e
you all right oh man he beat
me oh man Ethan beat
me you can add that to your resume yeah
I beat my mother I go I can beat you too
probably all right okay I lost I
lost you about to have your
babies just a few more weeks let's check
you and see if you're about see how
close you are let's take a look at that
udder
nope nothing yet look oh Duck's taking a
swim in the water like your not supposed
to this is the best part about living in
Arizona you get to have a winter garden
I love
it and you know I've been gardening
about 8 years and I still don't feel
like an expert you know I'm still
just throwing things in the ground and
trying things out and that's really
that's what gardening's about just kind
of learning how to do it all you know
each season that you grow you get a
little bit better you start predicting a
little you know what's going to grow
well you know what's not going to grow
so
well that's the best
part making the rounds here checking on
the garden checking on the compost
throwing some more goat poop in
there you guys having fun fun
yeah nothing better than a good morning
of goat
poop yep okay let's mix
it looking good yep it's going to really
help my garden when everything starts to
get bigger and start to produce more
fruit M did you just say produce more
poop I said fruit oh but I then I
thought you know we're growing more
Roots so produce more root let's go
check on the chicken coop see if we got
any eggs who's laying right
now freaking
out oh it's the freak out
chicken somebody's got the favorite
spot who has it I don't
know oh wow
we're starting to diversify now uh oh no
that's the loud one he never seems to
get the spot
yeah well if you're always late it's
like early bird catches the worm yeah
you're always late to the game man you
got to take a middle
spot oh good put him in there he's still
peeking over the other one yeah he's
like can I have that one when I first
made this I had curtains over it little
curtains over it so that they would feel
like they had this
little private space that would be funny
to do wouldn't it young I I remember
that you remember that so funny they go
in their curtains and they they be
peeking their head out and they'd have
you know little curtains around their
face them up there would try to like
bite me go
away all right I think that's it for
this
morning done with the chores check the
tire for eggs okay I'll go check the
tire
remember how you guys used to climb this
tree when you were little yeah but and
you go all the way up there I'm a little
too big to climb around it
now pretty big it's got lots of memories
it does you remember when Ethan pulled
out my hair oh yikes I remember that
actually mom no
eggs how you doing Ethan PR good you too
big no
dad does pull-ups on these okay let's
see if you can do a pull-up
pull okay
go I can't do pull-ups on that okay
video me see if I can do pull-ups okay
okay
will we
watching you can't do
pull-ups yeah there you
go just put your feet on that tire and
then you you can do it okay let's see if
you can do it Ean let's go okay go Ethan
then dad's going to show us his skills
you can do it over here this one's
easier to crab right here no way it's
look at oh
nice good
job dad is Master oh Dad can't do it
he's too
weak this one's got a weird angle
CB
N9 10 10 she's watching you picked
leaves I can see it in her eye look it
she's right she's over there under the
tree oh you got her a
bouquet let's see if she likes it she's
looking at
you here I got you a bouet of flowers oh
oh you're going to eat them oh okay I
guess you can do whatever you want with
them you don't want to put them in like
a base or anything no no okay that's
fine oh duck do you want some
leaves no oh oh
he's
like okay he's considering it okay we
got to go share you got to give some to
Luna fair oh she's like get away from my
leaves get away she doesn't have the
energy I think Luna wants to okay let's
go give some to Luna Luna oh they love
these mulberry leaves I love
them she want them oh
AOSS oh you just got sneezed on by a
[Music]
sheep
oh that's gross oh
gross there you
go I put up on the
[Music]
oh Dora's drinking out the water Dora
you drinking in the duck water have the
ducky poo water that's
poopy hi Penny we're back but we don't
have any leaves oh we have these leaves
okay give her one of those it's like
chips they're like mini like potato
chips Lydia's tasted these leaves before
what hey oh Dora are you okay a Dora are
you okay Dora sorry I'm sorry Penny's
really mean to you she is mean she's got
to get out of the way come here
Dora stay away we got attack
goats stay away attack sheep and attack
ducks and attack goats there
oh Dora
Penny stay sit sit do Shake okay Shake
oh good doggy good girl Laura she's a
good dog
[Music]